I live my life a quarter mile at a time
nothing else matters
for those 10 seconds or less
the open road could take you anywhere to
friends to family we know he's an
O'Conner but he's also a Toretto Salalah
for adventure let's do it to see
something new
what do you mean dream just to come back
home again the fastener Firoz saga has
explored the endless possibilities of
the open road from the streets just
outside downtown Los Angeles we've taken
you to Miami we've taken you to Tokyo
reowww
Londyn Abu Dhabi and now our name is
known all over the world
we have raced for speed race lauranna to
Damas had you greens or cities tumbled
down mountains and even dropped out of
the sky but no matter how our adventures
grow fast and furious is always about
one very important thing
that the most important thing in life
will always be the people in this room
it's a little differently our family of
characters do everything for each other
and with each other
for the millions who make up our global
family of fans we push ourselves to go
further and do better time after time
we never ride alone we never ride alone
we never ride alone disseminate just
about being fast now we embark on our
next chapter our family will be
challenged like never before
by adversaries who show no mercy testing
that bond that has always kept us
together
most ambitious most entertaining fastest
and most furious Rania
is fast and furious
you
you